bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 sport tout de suite on
passe au sommaire en val montigny le
bretonneux peut toujours espérer
accrocher le podium de nationale 2
féminine après sa victoire contre gagné
interview à suivre avec l'entraîneur
philippe étrange le coach sera
accompagné de la gardienne julie vulliez
et de l'ailière droite carole 8 et les
serres rugby polémique à versailles le
club ne peut pas jouer le championnat de
france à cause d'une anomalie dans le
règlement tous les détails sont à suivre
dans ce magazine course automobile ligne
montrent un stéphane panepinto a terminé
troisième du trophée au maserati world
series sur le circuit paul ricard dans
le bar où ils recevront dans cette
émission pour décrypter ces bons
résultats et puis en fin d'émission
comme tous les lundis nous ferons un
point sur tous les résultats sportifs du
week-end dans le département maintenant
place à nos premiers invités
ce week-end le club de mon tibre tenu à
remporter son match contre gagné à
l'extérieur sur le score de 30 à 19 une
victoire qui permet aux signé monteyne
de rester conserver leur quatrième place
dans ce championnat de nationale 2 à
deux journées de la fin du championnat
le club et même à égalité avec le 3e du
classement aubervilliers pour parler de
ce match de la fin du championnat de
montigny nous recevons sur ce plateau le
coach philippe l'étrange la gardienne
julie vuillier et laly et l'ailière
carole mittelheisser bonsoir
vous avez emporté donc ce match avec dix
buts d'avancé
tout simplement est ce que le match où
il avait rendu facile ou est ce qu'il
est et six ans que ça n'était pas simple
parce qu'aucun match est simple
surtout ils ont rencontré l'équipe de
gagner qui jouaient pour pas descendre
faut absolument que la gagne pour
toujours espérer rester en nationale 2
on a mis une mi-temps et puis après
alors peut-être que gagner à baisser de
régime et puis nous on a eu très peu
d'échecs aux tirs ce qui nous a permis
de prendre le large assez facilement sur
la deuxième mi temps et qu'est ce qui a
fonctionné du coup carole
c'était c'est l attaque vraiment à
fonctionner vous avez quand même marqué
30 buts sur cette rencontre les
automatismes et cellartis la défense
c'est ce qui nous a permis de ne pas
prendre l'eau parce que gagner était
très en forme sur la première mi-temps
est par contre ont gagné que d'un but
justement à la mi temps alors que en
deuxième mi temps on a commencé à
enchaîner les contre attaques ce qui
nous a permis de du coup de jouer
beaucoup plus libéré et d'enchaîner à la
fin du match c'était une équipe que vous
connaissez bien oui ça fait plusieurs
saisons qu'on les joue maintenant on
connaît leurs faiblesses on connaît
leurs points forts on sait qu'elle
s'énerve très rapidement et donc
justement fallait pas lâcher à la
mi-temps et direct
enfoncer le clou au retour du vestiaire
pour justement ne pas leur permettre de
revenir et du coup je vivier ce cet
aspect psychologique il a joué sur cette
rencontre vraiment oui il va jouer puis
pour moi c'est que c'est un match un peu
particulier contre gagné parce que j'ai
mes anciennes coéquipières qui font
partie de cette équipe donc moi c'est
une équipe que je craignais mais on a su
on a su élever notre niveau de jeu on
sortait plusieurs défaites on avait à
coeur surtout de gagner et voilà on a pu
imposer notre jeu gagne manqué de
banques et de fonds aussi et il ya
d'autres matches on les aurait peut-être
perdu mais messieurs là on l'a gagnée on
s'est donné les moyens il a fait du bien
c'est victor et fut vraiment vraiment du
bien vous avez concédé seulement 19 buts
sur cette partie vous même vous avez
réalisé quand même un match c'est
correct avec six parades est-ce que vous
avez été aussi peut-être la clé du match
au final la clé je sais pas après ce
avec le poste de gardien de but est
assez particulier on dépend énormément
de la défense ça faisait longtemps que
j'avais pas vu cette défense là j'avais
des filles qui avaient envie qu'ils
combattaient du coup les tirs sont plus
faciles à arrêter on dira que poste de
gardien de but fut très dépendante de
mes joueuses et nous ont vraiment aidés
et donc la défense a répondu présentes
sur ses congés acquittement exactement
je pense que on les a expliqués en
défense et auteur du beaucoup de balles
et puis derrière on a déjoué ce qui
courent des joueurs qui vont vite et on
a su en profiter et tant mieux vous êtes
4e actuellement au championnat au
classement du championnat national 2 à
deux journées de la fin du championnat
est ce que les objectifs sont remplis
tout simplement on devait terminer dans
les 5 premiers c'était l'objectif
principal du club n'est pas maintenant
on s'est mis un peu à rêver au cours de
la saison et on sait une saison mitigée
oui on n'en remplissent l'objectif et
puis on est un peu déçu parce qu'on a
une première place et une deuxième place
assez assez longuement pendant la saison
justement il n'y a pas un petit regret
sur sur cette saison vous étiez premier
au mois de février vous avez enchaîné
une mauvaise série de cinq 5 défaites
sur les six derniers matches avant cette
victoire contre contre gagny est-ce
qu'il ya pas ce petit regret ce de se
dire on aurait pu monter cette année
bien sûr on je sais pas parce que quand
même val d'or chez une très grosse
équipe la réserve du havre c'est une
belle équipe et nous est ce qu'on avait
le mental pour pour monter on peut se
poser les questions maintenant il est
tout un plein de circonstances qui ont
fait qu'on a perdu tout un tas de
matches et u17 du papa de gabriel
parloir qui n'a pas aidé contre val
d'orge qui après des blessures à
répétition de de carole de de fanny jean
baptiste de mes deux jeunes arrières
nous bénézis et clémence campagne et à
chaque fois on a eu des blessés des
blessés ça a été compliqué surtout
c'était les matches importants là à ce
moment là on n'a pas joué avec l'équipe
complet maintenant l'équipe au complet
je sais pas si on aurait gagné
parce que je crois que le mental c'est
facile d'être outsider mais quand on est
premier après tout le monde nous attend
et il faut avoir un mental d'acier
peut-être que c'est encore un peu trop
tôt
cette année vous manque et peut être un
peu devant cette année
non je pense port je pense qu'il y avait
il y avait des jeunes incorporés il y
avait des anciennes qui étaient là n'ont
peut-être là
le mental peut-être les aussi peut-être
le gros effectif qui a peut-être
perturbé certaines joueuses qu'on avait
l'habitude de toujours être prises je
sais pas après faut répondre on discute
entre nous pour préparer l'avenir carole
vous êtes d'accord avec philippe étrange
et peut-être quelque chose à jouer cette
saison mais finalement vous n'avez
peut-être pas les armes oui certainement
parce que c'est pas pour rien non plus
qu'on était première un certain niveau
du championnat et oui forcément les
blessures
ça ça tout de suite ça affaiblit
l'équipe et puis ça affaiblit
certainement le mental des filles qui
restent et qui se disent on va forcément
affaiblie pour jouer et après on ne sait
pas ce qui aurait pu se passer on aurait
très bien pu perdre également avec les
filles qui étaient blessés on saura
jamais mais ça n'a pas aidé julie c'est
monty python constante évolution depuis
deux trois saisons est ce que justement
l'équipe peut passer un palier le palier
des dur à franchir moi j'ai eu la chance
de pouvoir franchir à plusieurs reprises
et je pense je suis à chasser d'accord
avec philippe c'est que je pense
mentalement qu'on a qu'on a un petit peu
flanché face à voir en début d'année
quand je parlais un petit peu avec les
autres équipes on ne voyait absolument
pas dans les cinq premiers généralement
c'était val d'orge qui ressortait le
avoue même gagner et je pense que cette
place de deuxième nous convenait parce
qu'on était là en challenger et dès
qu'on a commencé à faire peur à
impressionner les autres équipes peut
être qu'on n'a pas su tenir la pression
et c'est là qu'on a on commence à
enchaîner les défaites et je pense que
mentalement on était peut-être pas prête
encore à assumer cette première place
est effectivement l'effectif est
beaucoup dans une montée mais le mental
fait fait encore plus et on n'était pas
prêt il ya eu un déclic cette saison
peut être par rapport aux saisons
précédentes
le premier déclic pour moi il est arrivé
ça peut pas évident mais face à wavre
premier match de la saison on perd moins
15 ça nous met tout de suite dans le
bain et là je me suis dit avec quelque
chose à faire avec cette équipe là est
derrière on a fait de très belles
performances et tout de suite on a
montré quand même un certain niveau de
jeu et une certaine qualité de jeu et
moi dès le début j'ai cru je l'avais en
début d'année à philippe que j'étais là
pour monter en n1 que je voulais revivre
ce projet là carole aussi on faisait
partie donc moi je pense effectivement
que qu'on avait une belle équipe et de
l'année dernière j'étais sur les jeunes
et qu un rôle aussi peut on parler
puisque cette année on s'occupe
particulièrement des jeunes ayez un
vivier chez les jeunes qui est vraiment
vraiment intéressant et je pense que
justement d'arriver à mélanger ses
cadres et ses jeunes va nous permettre
dans les années à venir de monter le
niveau cerveau qui a de l'avenir c'est
un groupe qui a de l'avenir parce qu'il
ya des quatre qui sont très importants
qui sont en place et il ya des jeunes
derrière dans les moins de 18 ans n'a
quand même cinq qui sont paul et je
pense que ces jeunes là vont pour
apporter peut-être la fou qui nous
manquer et nous l'expérience donc
philippe étrange on a deux journées de
la fin du championnat est ce que vous
préparez déjà la saison prochaine et
demi ça se prépare dès à présent la
saison 2015 2016 bien sûr en laissant
même les filles à l'extérieur finir leur
championnat mais on a déjà des contacts
les jeunes bas ils ont des finalités de
championnat de france à effectuer donc
on va les laisser un peu tranquille on a
commencé à incorporer des gamines de 17
ans donc
oui on peut pas en faut la préparer là
si on veut avoir des ambitions année
prochaine haute que terminé les cinq
premiers vous avez ciblé des des
joueuses en particulier oui on a ciblé
des joueuses parce qu'il a il va y avoir
forcément quelques départs chez nous les
filles qui ont décidé d'arrêter ou qui
vont changer de club
donc il faut qu'on les remplace et qu'on
les remplace même perdu du pew défini
avec beaucoup d'expérience pour
justement aider les les jeunes pousses à
un mur rien donc vous avez plutôt
recruter expérimenté plutôt que
incorporer des jeunes on va incorporer
des jeunes et recruter expérimenté
justement pour aider les jeunes à
s'aguerrir
c'est l'avenir donc signé dans quelques
années les chaînes donc
falloir les aider et c'est ça qui peut
vous faire passer un palier vraiment oui
tout à fait façon on n'a pas d'argent
pour aller chercher des joueuses pros
donc on est obligé de passer par les la
formation et
il ya eu des filles avec julie quand tu
es champion de france l'année dernière
donc on va incorporer cette année
j'espère que vos biens familiaux vote
donc mais il faut que la mayonnaise
prenne
et la saison prochaine à se fera avec
vous à philippe étrange peut-être
peut-être mais pour l'instant on fait en
sorte qu'elle se fasse avec mois après
rien n'est décidé
ils vont discuter avec les dirigeants et
surtout les choses vous aussi jolies
paroles ce projet peut-être de monter en
nationale une vous y adhérer
complètement pas forcément projet de
monter c'est toujours très intéressant
après comme dit il reste encore deux
journées on on se concentre pour le
moment sur le championnat avant de
réfléchir l'année prochaine donc
objectif monter les prochaines l'année
prochaine dans le var les deux premiers
si on a tout le monde oui bon c'est sûr
ça c'est sûr c'est l'objectif
merci à tous les trois d'être passé sur
ce plateau vous souhaite bonne chance
pour cette fin de saison ces deux
derniers matchs et bon courage pour
accrocher le podium qui je pense est
réalisable je pense
merci on passe maintenant au rugby
on
continue ce magazine par une polémique
que le club de rugby de versailles ne
participera pas aux championnats de
france excellence b la faute à un point
du règlement établi par la fédération
française de rugby la qualification
avait pourtant été validé sur le terrain
par après une victoire contre beauvais
combinée à une défaite double sur le
terrain de courbevoie le montage est
signée romain respini williams elle pour
les images
le bonheur aura été de très courte durée
le 19 avril dernier le rugby-club de
versailles pensait avoir arraché sa
qualification pour les championnats de
france d'excellence b en remportant son
match contre beauvais sur le score de 26
à 8 mais c'est finalement ou qui a
validé son ticket pour la compétition
sur tapis vert malgré sa défaite contre
courbevoie la raison le classement
général du championnat était totalement
remaniée suite au forfait d'hérouville
le problème c'est que l'écart en forfait
et bien sûr il perdait le match 25 0
mais comme il avait déjà deux forfaits
dans l'année il ya qui est déclaré
forfait général et au règlement dit que
quand un club est forfait général on re
calcul tout le classement et tous les
clubs ont joué contre cet adversaire la
gagne les gagne les matches par 25 0
avec le point de bonus offensif
pour versailles nous on avait gagné les
deux rencontres avec le point de bonus
offensif donc on avait déjà 10 points 2
x 5 donc on a gagné rien par contre où
il y avait perdu à hérouville avec zéro
point donc c'est retrouver le mercredi
soir ou jeudi avec cinq points en lieu
et place des 0 point qu'ils avaient une
véritable déception pour les joueurs de
la cité royale les rugbymans versailles
avait redoublé d'efforts à
l'entraînement ces derniers mois pour
arracher leur qualification puis d'avant
la déception a été très grande pour les
joueurs qui encore le jeudi soir pensé
qu'ils allaient jouer en 32e de finale
le dimanche d'après quand on sait que la
qualification en championnat de france 1
pour les joueurs de rugby c'est le graal
c'est la conquête quoi donc c'est une
très grosse déception il a fallu tourner
la page suite à cette annonce versailles
a contacté le département des
compétitions de la fédération française
de rugby pour demander des explications
donc actuellement nous sommes en train
de contacter la fédération nous allons
faire une lettre recommandée pour
expliquer quand même que si des
règlements sont existe il faut quand
même essayer de voir un peu les allées
de les modifier ou d'ajuster parce qu'un
premier un règlement en tout cas doigté
et équitable la saison des versailles
est donc terminée le club va préparer
dès à présent d'exercice 2015 2016 pour
la petite histoire où il s'est fait
éliminer dès le premier tour des
championnats de france par rennes après
deux défaites 30 à 15 et 26 à 7
il n'y monte un stéphane panepinto est
un as du volant les chinois a terminé à
une très belle troisième place au trofeo
maserati world series sur le circuit
paul ricard dans le var nous avons la
chance de recevoir le pilote sur notre
plateau bonsoir ok alors première
question pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas à cette catégorie ce coup pour nous
la présenter tout simplement trofeo
maserati world series donc c'est une
formule monotype on a tous les mêmes
voitures tout est géré organisé par
maserati quand c'est donc italie le
service compétition et on a tous le même
set up donc les mêmes réglages sur
chaque circuit après c'est à nous de
trouver
la bonne façon de piloter sur chaque
circuit avec la voiture qu'on prépare
donc il n'ya pas de soucis de réglage ou
quoi que ce soit on a juste la pression
des pneus à trouver la bonne pression
pour pouvoir avoir le meilleur grip au
bon moment donc c'est une compétition
assez équitable au final c'est voilà
c'est exactement c'est fait pour ça
après c'est vrai que le travail de
pression de recherche de pression est
très importante et déterminante sur le
maintien du pneu en bonne condition
pendant toute la course il ya beaucoup
de pilotes engagés sur cette compétition
une trentaine sur chaque meeting à peu
près et c'est une compétition qui se
déroule à travers le monde alors oui
c'est un world series donc avec six
manches la première cette année était au
paul ricard dans le sud de la france
près de toulon le castel exactement
ensuite il ya red bull ring en autriche
de course aux etats unis une au japon et
la finale à abu dhabi et qu'est ce qui
vous a attiré dans cette discipline vous
avez fait un petit peu de tout dans
l'automobile j'ai testé vous
effectivement pu déjà brillé dans plutôt
petit 1 ouais depuis que j'ai 15 ans
j'ai commencé à 15 ans donc j'ai fait du
kart comme tout le monde plusieurs
formules et 35 ans a plongé de 35 ans
plusieurs formules
notamment de la cat et ramda formule
renault la monoplace un peu de proto et
ce qui m'attire dans cette formule c'est
déjà la voiture la maserati ensuite le
championnat qu'un championnat mondial et
puis la compétition qui se passe au
travers de cette forme de cette formule
et donc sa fonctionnalité sponsors aussi
obligatoirement sauf si on a le
porte-monnaie personnel ce qui n'est pas
mon cas donc on est constamment en
recherche de partenaires et cette année
donc je travaille avec deux personnes
une en france et une aux états unis pour
la recherche de partenariats pour
pouvoir pratiquer cette saison le club
et ça coûte cher de participer à cette
compétition ça coûte à peu près deux
cents mille euros pour faire le
championnat complet et est ce que c'est
une compétition qui est usante aussi
physiquement on sait que par exemple et
les pilotes de formule 1 perdre en
général deux à trois kilos par grand
prix est ce que c'est pareil pour vous
danse dans ce trophée à maserati c'est
un peu moins fatigant que la f1 et parce
qu'on n'a pas de grippe a hero comme
e.on après c'est fatigant parce que
c'est des courses
d'endurance on rentre dans une ambiance
puisqu'elles font en moyenne 45 minutes
et ensuite mentalement parce qu'on doit
être concentré pendant tout ce temps-là
pas faire d'erreur faire attention à
tout ce qui se passe autour de soi
éventuellement dépasser des
retardataires ou alors gérer celui qui
est derrière nous et qu'ils essaient de
nous doubler
et vous préparer physiquement pour pour
ces compétitions j'ai un an les
commandes classiques classiques comme
tout sportif même de base c'est à dire
que je cours je cours j'essayais de
m'alimenter correctement aussi parce que
ça c'est important mais voilà j'ai pas
après un entraînement physique qui très
important non plus il ya quand même des
exigences à avoir au quotidien oui et
puis de toute façon vu que je pratique
ce sport depuis presque vingt ans j'ai
on va dire que j'ai musclé les bons
muscles au travers de toutes ces années
donc
aujourd'hui j'ai les capacités physiques
pour faire
ce sport évoquons visé a régulièrement
vous entraîner sur circuit m'a tout est
une question de budget donc pour
l'instant je m'entraîne sur les journées
qu'on nous offre c'est-à-dire le
vendredi avant chaque course c'est à
dire très peu de fois et vous avez donc
réalisé une très belle course lors de
cette dernière course il ya deux
semaines sur sakli paul ricard c'est un
circuit mythique est ce que c'était un
tracé qui vous convenait à merveille on
va dire il me convient et
j'ai trouvé rapidement mes marques c'est
pour ça que j'ai réussi à faire
jolie troisième place je peux le dire et
m'en vanter parce que c'est justement
maintenant vraiment compliqué ça c'est
compliqué parce qu'il faut quand même
apprendre la voiture c'est ma deuxième
course dans cette catégorie le circuit
fallait aussi que j'apprenne on a eu des
conditions un peu compliqué parce qu'on
a eu de la pluie pour les essais qualifs
et du sec sur le reste des manches donc
il a fallu s'adapter à chaque fois par
exemple pour la pluie je connaissais pas
la voiture sous la pluie je connaissais
pas le circuit non plus donc il a fallu
que je trouve rapidement les bonnes
trajectoires les bons points de freinage
pour faire le meilleur temps possible et
on n'avait que quatre tours à ce moment
là donc c'est être un exercice un peu
compliqué et puis
je me suis qualifié en troisième
position pour repartir
et qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence
durant cette course c'est peut-être
votre abnégation a jamais lâché ouais
ouais quoi qu'il a volontairement
et puis il fallait absolument que je
fasse un résultat déjà pour pouvoir
séduire des partenaires pour leur
montrer que j'étais capable d'être
devant devant dans ce plateau là et les
séduire pour leur donner envie de
peut-être investir et de communiquer au
travers de ma voiture qui déjà est un
pour un c'est fort de communiquer sur le
tour de course maserati des valeurs
quand même assez importante dans ce
sport et donc il fallait que je puisse
séduire ça ceux à qui je suis en train
de démarcher et les futurs qu'ils ont
peut-être envie de de passer par un
partenariat à ce niveau et quels sont
vos objectifs du coup pour la suite de
la saison c'est de ramener le trophée
alors mon déjà je participe aux deux
premières positions pionnat très
certainement à la dernière à la finale
parce qu'elle est importante et je me
suis mangé positif c'est de chercher des
moustiques des partenaires pour pouvoir
faire le championnat complet et
m'inscrire au championnat marqué des
points sur la totalité le championnat
donc de course aux etats unis une course
au japon
celle-ci j'aimerais vraiment à la faire
parce que c'est un circuit mythique tous
les pilotes je pense rêve de rouler à
suzuka
et voilà c'est mon objectif est bien sûr
de marquer un maximum de points sur les
trois manches auxquelles je vais
participer et c'est une catégorie dans
laquelle vous voulez évoluer sur
plusieurs années peut-être ou ailleurs
d'autres catégories qui peuvent vous
intéresser il y en a d'autres je vise
déjà à court terme donc 2010 est de
faire la saison complète en tout cas de
mon assuré
2016 pardon déjà en avance et 2000
peut-être 2017 y aurait peut-être un
programme maserati en gt3 championnats
d'europe en championnat du monde par
d'endurance et j'aimerais faire partie
de la liste des pilotes recruté par
maserati donc de faire de belles courses
est cette saison une très belle saison
2016 la gagner pour pouvoir peut-être
l'envisager en 2017 voilà et comme tout
pilote un jour faire les 24 heures du
mans c'est mon objectif actuel merci à
vous d'être passé sur ce plateau bonne
continuation aux racines votre votre
carrière du coup et la prochaine course
je rappelle ce sera sur le circuit de
red bull ring en autriche le 24 mai
prochain on passe maintenant reste de
l'actualité sportive du week-end dans le
département
c'est officiel la piscine de maurepas va
officiellement fermé ses portes un audit
a démontré que plusieurs éléments de la
structure subissent une corrosion
avancée qui menace la stabilité de la
piscine conséquence les animations
seront évidemment suspendu en attendant
une possible réhabilitation des locaux
dans les prochains mois ou une la
construction d'un nouveau centre
nautique le club de plongée de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines plongera
désormais à la palme plaisir oise des
clayes-sous-bois ou à montfort l'amaury
en football les matches de l'étoile
sportive de trappes ont été annulés ce
week-end une décision prise par un
arrêté municipal suite au décès par
balles du jeune moussa conté attrapé à
la blessure de daouda de janisson s'il
peut dans le club de saint quentin en
yvelines pour le président de travaux
mustapha larbaoui c'était la meilleure
solution à prendre on les écoute je ne
voyais pas jouer je ne voyais pas offert
aux freins jour jeu des temps le recul
que d'aller voir je vais voir des
familles que de retrouver les éducateurs
ou retrouver prochainement pour
il faut il ya un après à mon sens
la meilleure chose à faire
même si on fait qu' il faudra compter
évidemment
un bon
fallait pas créé de
profiter
l'équipe senior de trappes jouera le 17
mai prochain sur le terrain de la
parisienne en division honneur de
football l'espoir d'une montée en cfa2
s'est arrêté ce week-end pour versailles
l'équipe s'est incliné 2 à 1 contre
l'avant dernier du classement melun qui
a réalisé un match surprenant sur la
pelouse du stade mont boron une
contre-performance qui coûte très cher
au versailles et au classement les
versaillais sont toujours deuxièmes du
championnat mais se retrouve relégué à
huit points du leader saint maur à trois
journées de la fin de la saison
versailles restera donc en division
honneur cette année devrait figurer
parmi les favoris du championnat la
saison prochaine
toujours en football mais cette fois ci
en première division de district et
l'encours n'y arrive toujours pas et
saint quentinois ont perdu à l'extérieur
contre la celle-saint-cloud score final
2 buts à 0 une équipe qui lutte
également pour sa survie dans ce
championnat
au classement très mauvaise opération
pour l encours l'équipe reste à la 11e
place du championnat avec 28 points
engrangés en 19 journées et elle en
courtois pourrait même se retrouver
derrière guyancourt 6e but en courant
porte son match en retard le classement
de ce championnat de première division
de district est toujours dominé par
maurepas enfin il y avait du tennis ce
week-end ont disputé les finales de
l'open de tennis des encours ce samedi
chez les dames c'est la russe soyouz a
fait le saut va qui est sorti vainqueur
de son duel face à lafrançaise magalie
girard le score est assez sévère 6 2 6 0
dans un match très disputé qui a duré
plus de 1h30 chez les hommes pas de
surprise c'est le favori rudy coco qui a
soulevé le trophée sur le court suzanne
lenglen du parc des sports guy boniface
le français a dominé et leanne hichan à
un joueur formé dans les yvelines le
score 7 5 3 6 6 en un peu plus de 2h30
on passe à l'agenda du week end il y
aura du football américain ce samedi
avec les templiers d'elancourt les élans
courtois russell les argonautes
d'aix-en-provence ce samedi donc à 20
heures au complexe sportif europe ce
sera le match de la dernière chance pour
les saint quentinois actuellement la
sixième place du classement les
templiers peuvent encore espérer
accrocher une place en coupe d'europe
pour cela ils doivent impérativement
remporter leur match ce week-end ce ne
sera pas simple les argonauts sont
deuxièmes du classement avec un match en
moins un autre rendez vous à ne pas
manquer en baseball les cougars de
montigny-le-bretonneux reçoivent le
deuxième du classement clermont ferrand
ce dimanche à partir de 11 heures au
stade jean maréchal c'est la rencontre à
ne pas perdre pour les cougars les saint
quentinois sont pour l'instant l'avant
dernière place du championnat une
victoire contre clermont ferrand
pourrait leur permettre de croire encore
à une montée en première division il y
aura également du handball à montigny le
bretonneux les y monte 1 reçoivent
lisieux pour le compte de la 21e journée
du championnat
un match qui s'annonce plutôt facile
pour montigny les filles philippe et
tronçon quatrième du classement les
joueuses de lisieux pointe quand elle à
la 10e place si vous voulez soutenir
monty bretonneux la rencontre est
programmée samedi à 20h30 au gymnase
pierre de coubertin c'est la fin de ce
set 8 sport merci de l'avoir suivi je
vous retrouve lundi prochain pour un
nouveau magazine passé une excellente
semaine sportive très bonne soirée sur
tv fil 78